le voici ce document qui fâchent et
surtout sa première page sur le modèle
d'une célèbre collection
particulièrement mal venu pour le
syndicat cgt sont et sud côte-d'or les
agents de l'ehpad la saône se sont
sentis insultés
quand et lorsque ça dans leur
individuellement dans leur banet se sont
dit mais qu'est ce qu'on a fait quoi
on est vraiment des nuls voilà on vient
de perdre 42 résidents et on nous prend
pour des nuls donc oui forcément les
gens se sont se sont sentis atterré
voilà méprisé par la direction
ce guide des bonnes pratiques à recueil
de neuf pages sur les mesures de
protection adaptées aux qu'ovide a été
rédigé par le sépia ce le centre
régional d'appui pour la prévention des
infections associées aux soins
le document est téléchargeable sur son
site c'est ce qu'a fait la direction de
l'ehpad de saint jean de losne qui ne
comprends pas cette polémique le sépia a
été une instance qui nous a énormément
énormément aidé tant pour les médecins
vis-à-vis des médecins que les
infirmières vis-à-vis des personnels
soignants et il n'y a aucune
arrière-pensée de distribuer ce document
en plus le sépia ça fait ces documents
là pour le vulgariser auprès de la
population
milan a fait un qui est tout aussi
illégaux l'eau pour les enfants donc moi
je comprends pas bien mais bon
surpris lui aussi par l'émotion suscitée
par le titre de sa publication le sépia
cela modifier ce matin pour les nuls est
devenu plus sobrement pour tous